the federal government this morning
unveiled new updated guidelines for
physical activity the recommendations
aimed to help fight the obesity epidemic
that affects nearly forty percent of
American adults and adds nearly one
hundred and seventeen billion dollars to
health care costs first on CBS this
morning our dr. Tara Narula has a look
at the new recommendations for all
Americans Tara good morning good morning
John it's been 10 years since the first
physical activity guidelines were issued
and this morning's updates give
Americans more ways to reach those goals
the updated guidelines for adults allow
more flexibility counting short bursts
of exercise and activities such as
housework into the recommended weekly
total of a hundred and fifty minutes
the report says physical activity
reduces the risk of eight types of
cancer up from two in the previous
guidelines and for the first time the
government is adding recommendations for
three to five year olds these
preschoolers start their day on the run
to condition their bodies and their
minds you need to run around you need to
get the energy out and they actually
then focus and somehow the group and
then they can actually be more effective
in the class
Marguerite Sheehan says physical
activity is a priority for her three
children including four-year-old miles
you want to strengthen muscles early on
because we want the kids to start being
able to be independent activity is a big
we know that what happens early in
childhood really charts a course that
can last for decades
Admiral Brett shuwa helped craft the
guidelines for the Department of Health
and Human Services how is the future
different for kids who start by being
physically active children who have
unhealthy body weights even at three
four and five-year-olds are much more
likely to become obese later in life
these children should have about three
hours a day of activity and that could
be light exercise moderate exercise the
guidelines tell parents and caregivers
to encourage active play and to be
models of movement we go to the
playground unless it's really raining
bad or cold and even inside we do
different activities Ben Augustine
father of three-year-old Lena found one
strategy to overcome the pull of screen
time in addition to reading a book
trying to get them to play and it seems
like having a friend to do it with is
the best way exercise is important for
everyone by making a commitment to sit
less and be more active you decrease the
risk of certain cancers diabetes and
heart disease exercise is also good for
your emotional and cognitive health it
is linked to higher academic success and
reduced anxiety when I heard it three
hours a day I thought that seems like a
lot you said well Gail they're not on
treadmills although if well you know
what to do a three to five year old
what to me yes let's be clear done yeah
about the other ages right so for six to
17 year olds the recommendations are 60
minutes daily of moderate to vigorous
activity typically aerobic activity and
then three days a week to build in
muscle and bone strengthening exercise
it have to be contiguous or it can it be
blocked it does not it does not and
that's important but it really does fall
out of the burden on the parents to get
the kids moving it's only 39 states have
mandates for physical activity in
elementary schools and is it because
they're on their devices so much is that
why the officials now feel the need to
say look parents you got to do something
they definitely think that that's part
of the problems and we need to be aware
of that parents and kids are both on
devices too much unfortunately yes
yeah thank you